i did this um i did this retreat and you
know some of my boys are in the chat
right now you know i can see them we did
a
big ass uh dinner downtown toronto um
there's about 17 or 18 of us on uh
thursday night
and um
then a handful of us i think there was
eight um in total um as participants on
the heroes trip that um you know i took
them up north
got a got a nice place set up and
facilitator and you know took him on the
whole uh heroes trip and you know did
the inner work and the integrations and
all that stuff
and
you know there's always conversations
you know when guys get together and talk
and
start opening up on stuff that's going
on in their life with women with family
with business and all that kind of stuff
and it's like
one of the things that we did was we
went out for a bit of a stroll on you
know one of the days the weather was
not the greatest this weekend you know
we woke up you know in the morning with
snow on the ground once and it was
you know it was cold for the most part
but um it went for the stroll and then
we ended up by this um you know marina
and you know all the boats are still
stacked and out of the water and stuff
and there's a bunch of guys at the end
of the the pier that we're fishing we're
just walking and one of the guy goes
uh look out over there there's a there's
a pile of dog [ __ ] right
and i want to use that as an example
because
a smart guy that understands simplicity
out of complex issues will just identify
the problem
and walk around it
some people will identify the problem
and step in it and then complain about
the results that they get from stepping
in it
a lot of people it seems nowadays will
actually get down and examine it they
want to know what kind of a relationship
or sorry what kind of breed the dog was
what kind of a relationship the dog had
with its owner what it ate the night
before is it borderline personality
disorder is it npd
um does it have a narcissistic
personality trait to it um you know
you know sort of thing and why all of
that you know sort of stuff occurs
when
it's unnecessary
you've identified it [ __ ] you walk
around it and you carry on
and you know i've
i've been saying this and i'm going to
keep saying it because
i see a lot of guys spending far far too
much time
just dealing with problem [ __ ] that they
don't need to you know i'll use you know
problem women as an example because i
know most of you guys watching this are
uh men but it's like
you know
you see she's a problem it like it walks
like a duck it quacks like a duck it
waddles like a duck it floats on water
it dives like a duck you know it flies
like a duck it's a duck okay if it looks
like a problem it's going to be a
problem right again you know that whole
oakum's
razor again the simplest explanation is
generally the correct
one if the [ __ ] is crazy
that's all you need to know you don't
need to care about what her relationship
was with her father if she's a feminist
if she's a conservative if she's a
liberal why her hair is dyed purple what
shade of purple is used um does she
believe in abortion is she pro-choice is
she second amendment choice
it's like
all this time spent on nonsense when all
you got to do is look at and go
it's dressed like a red flag and it
marches like a chinese communist red
flag parade we're just not going to
invite that into our life okay
that's really just you know
the the beauty of the simplicity
is
not inviting crazy in your life who
cares why it's crazy who cares why that
[ __ ] is there who cares what breed that
is who cares what relationship that
breed has with its owner how old that
dog is what it had for dinner it doesn't
matter it's [ __ ] you just walk around it
you just keep moving and you walk around
it and you set it aside the problem is
there's too many guys today especially
when it comes to personal relationships
inviting nightmares in their life i had
a you know a bunch of private
conversations with a whole bunch of guys
over the last few days and um
you know a lot of it went around you
know the whammons you know a lot of it
was like you know i invited this crazy
chick in my life and this that and the
other thing happened
and now i'm dealing with the
consequences of that right and it's
expensive consequences and it's
time-consuming consequences
um and there's guys that legitimately
you know identify that they're taking
years off their life dealing with those
consequences
you know
and it's simple it really is simple
don't get involved
you know there's like
you know to to
to kind of tip my you know my hat a
little bit you know to the mgtow crowd
um you know the ones that are truly
choosing not sent you know their own way
the ones that are choosing to go their
own way you know sort of thing
there's
there's a simplicity in that you know to
some degree for the ones that execute it
properly
um you know the ones that spend
far too much time
just on on nonsense and you should come
to you know recognize what nonsense
looks like you know like it's a skill
that you have to develop as a guy like
you know
again if
if
somebody's rambling some [ __ ] to off to
you about an investment about a business
about
some new [ __ ] cryptocurrency or some
[ __ ]
like nft jpeg [ __ ] overpriced you
know what i'm talking about right like
if it just doesn't make any sense to you
and they're just going off about it for
[ __ ] ever it like no it's like the
answer is no absolutely [ __ ] not
right
um
again you know if it's not a hell yes
it's always a [ __ ] no
right
um
simplicity will save your life you know
if you don't have the capacity to make
like good calls like if you can't make
good calls and assess people and size
them up quickly and properly then then
that's going to affect you at some point
it's it's you know it's going to catch
up to you i don't know what happened to
randy i don't but smart guy successful
loads of money lots of cars donated lots
of calories you know
charities change lots of lives
took permanent steps to it whatever
temporary problem was going on in his
life i mean
you know this is this is where things
can go
if you can't simplify complex matters
you know that's that's again an extreme
example but this is where things can go
so
i invite you to um
you know the next time somebody starts
running their mouth about some [ __ ] for
minutes hours whatever it happens to be
investment opportunity their position on
women this is how you get whatever or
make more money or get the girls or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
no no it's it's you know like if it
sounds like too much work and it's too
complex then it it is
you know i can save you a lot of time
and money just on that alone that's it
simplify your life look for things that
fill your sails with wind and take you
to your new you know your next passage
your next protocol
and cut those anchors off man cut off
anything that that that like comes at
you
in a far too complex manner hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you